hey guys merry here at PAX East 2016 I'm
hanging out with Tony hey hey and as you
were at the devolver digital booth
checking things out you saw a pretty
sick game called ruiner on pc yes I did
alright I saw it on PC is also on linux
and mac so anybody with a home computer
okay able to play this and visually i'm
sure the audience can already see this
it's twin-stick top-down cyberpunk
madness it's got a really wicked visual
stuff yeah it feels like Blade Runner
the game it everything out of there
looks like the harrison ford movie you
know you've got you've got your kind of
ramshackle town but everybody's got
those cybernetic implants and everything
just feels off you know there's
something under the service that that
doesn't that doesn't sit right yeah tell
me a little bit about this story because
you're just like wandering around you're
shooting a lot of stuff and we'll get
into that in a second but like why what
are you doing right so so you're this
guy whose mind was hacked not like an
inception way but you know you were
messed with and you want to go get the
guy who messed with you and in fact the
demo I saw which I believe is the very
beginning the game as you're tracking
that guy down but as the cyberpunk
things go and as these sort of
conspiracy based stories go sure you can
find the guy who hacked your brain but
he's not the only guy out to get you you
know he's got a boss and that guy's got
a boss and that guy's got a ball and it
goes all the way to the top and to kill
all these people your kind of shooting
everybody in a similar to hotline Miami
which you said the developers said they
were inspired by it yes it feels very
hotline Miami um it is very fast but you
have to be very careful in fact guns are
usually supposed to be your backup you
have your melee weapons you have like a
katana a lead pipe that sort of thing
your enemies go down in a few hits but
so do you so you've got to be able to
dash around you've got to be able to put
your shield up enemies come at you with
guns they come at you with like Molotov
cocktails so you got to be moving and
you've got to be shooting right back at
them if you want to survive it sounds
like very fast-paced and very frenetic
and very stressful much like hotline
Miami but unlike hotline Miami
not one hit kill yeah it is not one hit
kill you do have a few hits you can take
and it absolutely is stressful it just
in the sense of like you have to get a
hang of that combat but when you do and
when you're able to take down a whole
like gang of enemies with no problem or
able to take down your first boss you
feel very accomplished doing that yeah
and it's all set to a pretty sick
soundtrack as well yeah I mean it's like
like we said blade runner cyberpunk to
do with that what you will you know it's
it's it's your beats it's your lasers
it's exactly what you expect the audio
follows the visual style definitely
alright sweet well that was ruiner and
you guys can look forward to that at
some point in the future TBA 20 16 2016
thanks a lot honey mm-hmm
you